good evening I'm Anne Thornton vice
provost and university librarian at
Columbia and it's my pleasure to welcome
you this evening the work of Richard
Hofstadter has rarely seemed more
relevant for prescient in fact this
panel planned as a centennial
observation has in the past two weeks
come to be far more relevant
Hofstadter's work on liberalism
conservatism paranoia reform and even
violence feels like it might have been
ripped from the headlines or Facebook
posts of this election cycle scanning
his body of work it's possible to see
parallels at many turns whether in the
impassioned pleas of free silver
advocates in the 1890s to the popularity
of anti-intellectualism in the 1950s to
his analysis of Barry Goldwater's appeal
to right-wing Republicans in the 1960s
born 100 years ago in Buffalo New York
and the actual anniversary fell in early
August richard hofstadter earned his PhD
at Columbia University in 1942 and
joined the faculty here in 1946 in 1949
he succeeded Allan Nevins as DeWitt
Clinton professor of history a position
currently held by Eric Foner one of
tonight's panelists his first major work
published in 1948 was the American
political tradition and the men who made
it which he followed up with numerous
other works including the age of reform
anti-intellectualism in American Life
the paranoid style in American politics
and American violence he was twice
awarded the Pulitzer Prize for these
works I say numerous other works but
actually there should have been many
more Hofstadter died too young in 1970
of leukemia at the age of 54 tonight we
are honored to hear reflections on Hoffs
ITER's life work and historical legacy
from distinguished panelists some of
whom knew him personally others who have
written very much in or at times against
his tradition or who have tackled some
of the states same historical moments as
Hofstadter himself focused on before we
turn to our panel first I'd like to
introduce a junior scholar of great
potential who has been working to create
an online exhibition featuring exciting
new discoveries from the Richard
Hofstadter papers which are held in the
Rare Book and Manuscript library of
Columbia Ben surbhi is a PhD candidate
in American history here where he
researches political ideologies and
social movements since the Second World
War and in particular the gay liberation
movement of the 1970s he is a Lehman
research assistant at the Rare Book and
Manuscript library and one of this
year's Andrew W Mellon pre doctoral
fellows in museum education at the
Museum of the city of New York
please help me welcome Ben surbhi thank
you very much well I only have a few
minutes to kind of introduce this
website that I've been putting together
for much of the last year and there are
a number of very fascinating documents
that I want to share I've kind of pared
it down to a few so I'll just cut right
to the chase and get started we're going
to move kind of chronologically now
basically the genesis of this project is
comes out of my work at the RB ml at the
rare book manuscript library when I was
looking through the Hofstadter papers
notice there are a number of very
fascinating documents I'm going right
back to Hofstadter's childhood and his
high school years in Buffalo New York
now this is a document that is it's not
exactly a great literary or historical
and
some document but it is a one-act play
that richard hofstadter wrote when he
was a high school student
yeah our panelists might want to move so
they can see and it's it's kind of a
satirical play that draws on this
bizarre situation between several
characters a butler named Jeeves and his
master and it actually broadcast on the
radio in Buffalo New York at the time
that the high school where he went
Fosdick Mastan Park High School had its
own radio station I'm not gonna really
belabor that too much but you're free
obviously this is a website it's it's
available now for you to browse and so
you can come back to any of these on
your own time I want to look at this
real quick this is the cover page of the
unpublished version of the introduction
to the American political tradition
Hofstadter's second book which this
introduction I think many people who are
fans of the American political tradition
obviously one of Hofstadter's most
influential and important books find the
introduction to be somewhat maybe
incommensurate to the the content of the
book itself which is a really rich and
really actually really entertaining read
and the unpublished version which i've
made available as a PDF has a lot more
in it than the version that we all know
and I think this quotation that you see
here from Karl Mannheim the Hungarian
sociologist of ideas yeah really kind of
captures some of the difference from the
published version which has I believe
it's a quote from John Dos Passos
instead and this this is a much kind of
darker
I think analysis of politics politics as
politics as possible only as long as the
realm of the irrational still exists I
also think that that might strike us is
very relevant right now
and then it has all these crazy a
marginalia all over it which I quite
like notes to himself I don't know
whether some of these might have been
notes that were added later by other
people but I highly encourage anyone
who's interested in the American
political tradition to take a look at
this this full-length introduction which
has a lot about the psychology of
politics and the irrational Oh a lot
drawing on on Freud in particular
unsurprisingly another document that's
I've made available in full aware this
is not the most visually striking
presentation of it right now is a
document called the New Deal in American
liberalism which is unbated but it has
to have been written I've deduced
probably around 1949 and I think many
people who are interested in
Hofstadter's political evolution from
kind of radical the 1930s to well some
might say a liberal perhaps a
conservative by the late 1960s in some
sense again these are loose terms tend
to think that by around 1950 he was
quite comfortable with the achievements
of the New Deal New Deal liberalism had
to be defended even if it wasn't exactly
the the best of all possible worlds but
this document is interesting because
there's a qualification that I don't
think you see in a lot of Hofstadter's
writing having to do with the rise of
the military-industrial complex or what
he calls using Harold Lasswell as term
the the garrison state and I'm not gonna
obviously scroll all the way through
this document again
I encourage you to to look at yourselves
but it's sort of an interesting peek at
Hofstadter at a moment where I think he
was in some kind of ideological
transition in in the late 1940s this is
a this is actually not something that
Hofstadter himself drew this is by Erich
McKittrick another historian some of you
may have read who was Hofstadter
graduate student and his research
assistant while he was working on the
age of reform the age of reform
obviously has a lot of material relating
to again the kind of the psychology of
politics the irrational and one of the
major criticisms of that book is that he
psychologize 'as the populist and the
progressives that he reduces their
politics to to psychology little else
and that there's something pathologizing
about that and so yeah we have this very
vivid image that Eric McKittrick drew he
also had a kind of I'm not going to show
you this right now but he had a kind of
a key that he drew out for Hofstadter
with a number of different symbols that
would guide hops that are through some
of the documents that he found so for
instance he would go through a newspaper
from a small town in Tennessee and he
would pick out all the things that
seemed relevant to some of the points
that Hofstadter wanted to make about
populism and a star for instance
represented anti-semitism or an asterisk
I'm kind of making these up but an
asterisk would represent something like
the banks and and they're quite colorful
and I do think that those are worth
looking at I won't just say a word about
this next tab here so Hofstadter of
course another thing that distinguishes
him I think besides you know the content
of his works themselves is that he was
he was really a public historian who's a
public intellectual who wrote for a very
broad audience there's a lot relating to
that we see correspondence from readers
and also reviews of his work in small
town newspapers which is I think also
kind of a curiosity from today's
standpoint we don't really have that
kind of a print culture as much anymore
but this is an audio recording of
Hofstetter I'm just gonna play a maybe a
minute of from 1954 and it was broadcast
actually we don't know what radio
station is there was nothing indicating
it in
the archives to be honest but from a
program called perspectives in American
art and it's Hofstadter talking about a
painting that he and his wife has second
wife Beatrice owned by the American
landscape painter Thomas Cole and so
it's just great because you get to hear
his voice so I'm just gonna let it play
and hopefully this works richard
hofstadter an art collector as well as
historian talking about another painting
of Thomas Cole Thomas Cole was born in
England in 1801 and came to America as a
youth he began painting here in his
early 20s and it was not very long
before he established himself as a
formidable figure among our landscape is
he was much admired by his
contemporaries such men as Thomas Doty
and Asher Durand thought him in some
respects their superior and he was
highly praised by James Fenimore Cooper
and William Cullen Bryant Bryant perhaps
hit him off best in a phrase when he
spoke of him as showing in his more
symbolic works an ardent imagination
he was constantly straining to break
away from work that was merely pictorial
the pastoral mood could not contain him
for very long even his relatively Placid
painting of the Oxbow of the Connecticut
is marked by contorted trees and a
lowering thunderstorm he moved with a
I'm terribly sorry I'm gonna cut him off
there but again this is all here it's
not going anywhere I'm just gonna show
you two or three more documents okay I'm
getting a signal one more document do i
flout my boss's authority um okay well
very quick one and a half all right so
this this is a list of historians who
participated in the march from Selma to
Montgomery in 1965 I'm not sure how many
people real I certainly didn't before
seeing this that Hofstetter
had participated in
he was kind of understand dragged down
by C Vann Woodward and then you know
obviously there's a lot in here relating
to 1968 and the events at Columbia and I
couldn't possibly cover all of it right
now but I do want to just gesture to
these two letters having to do with
Eldridge Cleaver this this is the week
before the Columbia crisis before the
occupation of buildings here at Columbia
and he's writing on behalf of the Black
Panther Party leader Eldridge Cleaver to
the California parole board saying you
know I've read his book he's a great
intellectual and please you know be
lenient there's also a letter where he's
trying to carve out kind of a middle
position to a supporter who is asking
him for a donation to the Eldridge
Cleaver Legal Defense Fund and he's kind
of he's saying I disagree with some of
the language in your letter this was not
just a confrontation with police this
was a shootout he was trying he's trying
to stake out a kind of a more moderate
position while at the same time he did
donate to the Black Panther Legal
Defense Fund and I think that that
speaks to some of the kind of
difficulties that he faced trying to
balance his way in a moment when I think
the center basically couldn't hold the
last thing these are nine letters from a
whole a whole slew of letters that were
sent to the editors of the American
heritage magazine the month that
Hofstadter died these reached those
editors just a number of days after he
passed away in 1970 and one of his last
published essays was called America as a
gun culture and he he lamented the lack
of stringent gun laws in this country
especially coming after a decade of
intense gun violence political
assassinations again all very eerily
familiar but but the thing about it is
he got all these letters sent in
response from various readers who wanted
to cancel their subscriptions to the
magazine and were very very up in arms
about some of what he had said calling
into question his patriotism his
credentials as a historian I invite you
to read them and I again the website is
the URL is here's richard hofstadter
100-ohm heh canet but it will eventually
be hosted by the Columbia library's
website so for now this is the URL that
anyone can use and feel free to come and
talk to me if you have any questions
about the website and I look forward to
hearing from our panelists so I'll just
stop there and leave you wondering what
else is on here all right okay all right
so let me introduce our panel and I'm
going to introduce all of them and I'm
not going to sit down and join all of
you so I can so I can enjoy the evening
let me start with Eric Foner DeWitt
Clinton professor of history at Columbia
who specializes in the civil war and
reconstruction slavery and 19th century
America his book the fiery trial Abraham
Lincoln and American slavery won the
Pulitzer Bancroft and Lincoln prizes for
2011 his latest book is gateway to
freedom - hidden history of the
Underground Railroad Elizabeth Cohen
Howard Mumford Jones professor of
American Studies in the history
department and Dean of the Radcliffe
Institute for Advanced Study at Harvard
is an expert on 20th century American
social and political history she is the
author of making a new deal Industrial
Workers in Chicago 1919 to 1939 which
won the Bancroft prize in American
history and a consumer's Republic the
politics of mass consumption in post-war
America Cohen's current book project
is entitled saving America's cities ed
Logue and the struggle to renew urban
America in the suburban age IRA
Katznelson has been Ruggles professor of
political science and history at
Columbia University since 1994 and since
2012 president of the Social Science
Research Council his work straddles
American and comparative politics and
political theory as well as political
and social history
his most recent book fear itself the New
Deal and or the origins of our time was
given the Bancroft prize in history
along with other awards adrian petty
associate professor of history at City
College specializes in the history of
the American South she is the author of
standing their ground small farmers in
North Carolina since the Civil War which
was awarded prizes from the southern
Historical Association and the
agricultural history Society her current
project is entitled breaking new ground
the history of african-american farm
owners in the south please help me thank
our panelists this is typical of the
modern age you can't get rid of this
thing paper in front of you all right so
I'm Eric Foner my job is to moderate the
panel and also give an introduction to
Richard Hofstadter's life and
intellectual life political life etc and
then each of the three others here we'll
talk about some aspect of Hoff status
career and then we will have a little
discussion and then open up to questions
and comments from the floor and then
there's wine and stuff out there too for
everyone to enjoy themselves so that's
what will happen this evening
as you heard richard hofstadter died in
1971 at the rather young age of 54
that's almost half a century ago but
despite the transformation
of historical writing that has taken
place since then HOF status works
continued to exert a powerful influence
on how both scholars and the general
public think about American history his
penetrating intellect and his sparkling
literary style helped to account for
this and Hofstetter still commands the
attention I think we'll hear tonight of
anyone who wishes to think seriously
about American history and especially
the history of political political
culture and the connections between
politics and society in this country
Hofstadter as you heard was born in 1916
in Buffalo New York he went to high
school there and then he came to
Columbia to do graduate work the
formative influence on him as a young
scholar was the Great Depression both
politically and intellectually he later
wrote the Depression started me thinking
about the world it was it was as clear
as day that something had to be done you
had to decide in the first instance
whether you were a Marxist or an
American liberal Hofstadter decided that
he was a Marxist and he read Marx and
Lenin and joined the young Communist
League at buff the University of Buffalo
when he came to Columbia as a graduate
student and married Felice widows the
sister of the well-known writer Harvey's
way tous they became part of the sort of
radical intellectual culture of the city
in the 1930s Hofstadter later wrote that
he was by temperament quite conservative
and timid and acquiescent which i think
is an exaggeration but nonetheless in
1938 he joined the Communist Party's
branch or a unit at Columbia
he wrote that this decision reflected a
kind of craving for action after quote
the hours I have said spent joying about
the thing he wrote to sway doses
brother-in-law I joined without
enthusiasm but with a sense of
obligation my fundamental reason for
joining
the Communist Party is that I don't like
capitalism and want to get rid of it I
am tired of just talking but Hofstetter
did not find himself very comfortable in
the Communist Party he left very quickly
in February 1939 but he continued to
think of himself at that point as a
radical he wrote this way DOS I hate
capitalism and everything that goes with
it
but after his little experience in the
party he would never devote his energies
in any sustained manner to a political
cause he became preoccupied with the
idea that intellectuals were even though
he didn't like their role in the current
society were not likely to find a home a
comfortable home in a socialist society
that was likely to emerge we are the
people he wrote that as intellectuals we
are the people with no place to go
Hofstede is early right earliest writing
reflected this sort of radical milieu
that he was part of his master's thesis
here in Colombia written in 1938 was
about southern sharecroppers a problem
that had become the focus of intense
organizing by socialists and communists
during the New Deal Hofstede's essay was
a devastating indictment of the
Roosevelt administration for pandering
to the undemocratic segregationist elite
of the south and it's it it laid out a
critical evaluation of Roosevelt that
would remain I think in hoff status
riding all the way through although on
other grounds as time went along
Hofstadter also wrote an essay on Ulrich
B Phillips the historian of slavery one
of the first direct attacks on
Phillips's sort of sugar-coated
depiction of American slavery which
Hofstetter called the plantation legend
this appeared in 1944 in the Journal of
Negro History which was an unusual venue
at that time for a white scholar so
Hough status general approach was shaped
at this point by Marxism but in fact
in relation to the American past it was
really the iconoclastic materialism of
Charles beard that was his greatest
inspiration beard he wrote was really
the exciting influence on me
beard taught as most of you know that
American history was shaped by the
struggle of competing economic groups
farmers industrialists factory workers
and that that's what politics was about
class self-interest underlying the
rhetoric of political leaders lay
economic interests the civil war for
example had little to do with slavery it
should be understood as a transfer of
political power from southern agrarians
to northern industrial capitalism
capitalism differences about the tariff
said beard have more to do with the with
the war than debates over slavery hub
status first published essay in 1938 in
the American historical review took
issue with beards emphasis on the tariff
as the fundamental cause of the Civil
War but accepted the premise that
economic self-interest was at the root
of everything he argued that the
homestead issue was more important than
the tariff as a source of tension
between north and south
but while beer devoted little attention
to political ideas seeing them as I said
is just a kind of mask for economic
self-interest Hofstadter soon became
attracted to the study of American
social thought he was influenced by
Merle Kerdi who supervised his
dissertation here a professor of
intellectual and social history at
Columbia / Hofstadter was not happy as a
graduate student at Columbia he was
denied financial aid the guys who got
the fellowships he wrote our little
ships who never accomplished or
published anything
graduate students appear to have needed
a union back then nonetheless at the
rather precocious age of 26 Hofstadter
completed his dissertation which was
published as his first book in 1944
social Darwinism in American thought the
book is about the impact on intellectual
life of the writings of Charles Darwin
and the growing use of Darwinian ideas
or language such as survival of the
fittest natural selection the struggle
for existence to reinforce conservative
lays a fair ideology in the late 19th
century Hofstadter wrote about how
social Darwinism sort of reigned supreme
in the 1880s 1890s and then how it came
under sustained attack from many sources
by clergymen shocked by the inequities
of the industrial order and but
particularly intellectuals of the
emerging social sciences Hoff status
hero in the book was John Dewey whom he
presented as a model of the socially
responsible intellectual the architect
of what have said I called a new
collectivism in which an activist state
attempted to guide and improve society
social Darwinism laid out basic themes
that would preoccupy Hofstadter for the
rest of his life the evolution of
political thought the social context of
ideologies and the role of ideas in
politics he kept recurring to those
questions again and again so social
Darwinism established him as a very
prominent young historian but in 1948 as
we heard it was the American political
tradition that really propelled him to
the forefront of historical scholarship
in this country as many of you know this
is a series of a brilliant series of
portraits of prominent Americans from
the founding fathers through to
Jefferson Jackson Lincoln FDR it's been
read by millions of people since its
publication has been you
in countless colleges and high school
classrooms Hofstadter's insight was that
basically all of these guys were the
same that instead of persistent conflict
whether between agrarians and
industrialists or capitalists and labor
or Democrats and Republicans American
history he wrote was characterized by
broad agreement on fundamentals
particularly individual liberty private
property and capitalist enterprise this
is the so-called consensus school that
the American political tradition became
a symbol of it marked his final break
with the beardian and Marxist traditions
which are based on conflict and along
with Daniel boorsteins the genius of
American politics and Lewis Hart says
the liberal tradition in America which
came out a few years later both of them
it became as I said a foundation of what
came to be called the consensus history
of the 1950s particularly because of the
introduction which I didn't even know
you have in the library a longer version
of that that's very interesting but
Hofstadter
we found this annoying actually that
people kept citing the introduction as a
kind of intellectual manifesto he once
told me I wrote the introduction like in
a day because the publisher when I was
about to go to press said this book
needs an introduction would you please
come up with something it but it later
became seen as a kind of manifesto of
consensus history which was not really
intended to be but the the real point is
that Hofstede is writing never devolved
into the uncritical celebration of the
American experience that characterized
much of this consensus writing in 1969
Arthur Schlessinger jr. wrote an essay
about historians in which he wrote that
there was a basic difference between the
American political tradition and Daniel
boorsteins consensus riding for
Hofstadter slays injure wrote and he
could have included hearts in this too
for Hofstadter perceived the consensus
from a radical perspective from the
outside and deplored it
while Borstein perceived it from the
inside and celebrated it in the Hofstede
of papers is a draft of this essay by
Slazenger which he sent to Hofstadter
and in the margin opposite this sentence
distinguishing him from Borstein
Hofstetter wrote in big letters thank
you and as they say he later came to
regret the emphasis that people placed
on the introduction so Hofstadter had
abandoned beards analysis of American
history but he retained beards kind of
iconoclastic spirit in the American
political tradition Jefferson is a
political chameleon Jackson is an
exponent of liberal capitalism not the
common man Lincoln was a myth maker
Roosevelt a pragmatic opportunist the
domination of individualism and
capitalism in American life produced not
a benign freedom from European
ideologies as Borstein would write but a
form of intellectual and political
bankruptcy this was a society
fundamentally he said that I was
incapable of producing an original idea
and therefore unable to confront the
modern world the consensus was a
straitjacket it was not just a form of
American superiority in that book just
as in social Darwinism Hofstadter seemed
to identify most of all with the engaged
intellectual the the one the one chapter
of a person who he actually seems to
admire is the abolitionist Wendell
Phillips the only person in the book who
never held a political office who
criticized the society from the from the
outside it's ironic that one of the most
devastating indictments of American
political culture ever written became
the introduction to American history for
two or three generations of students
well Hofstadter later wrote that this
first two book social Darwinism and the
American political tradition reflected
the experiences of the depression and
the
to deal in the 1950s a different set of
experiences began to shape his writing
the particularly the Cold War and
McCarthyism by then he was teaching at
Columbia and again part of an
intellectual world in New York but a
rather different one than from the 1930s
he wrote to Merle curry who had moved to
Wisconsin that he had quote grown a
great deal more conservative in the last
few years it is true that unlike many
New York intellectuals have said and
never made a career out of
anti-communism he didn't join the
Congress of cultural freedom didn't get
involved in that he was repelled by
McCarthyism he supported with that maybe
his last real political kind of
inspiration oddly enough was Adlai
Stevenson's campaign for the presidency
in 1952 running against the president of
Columbia right Dwight D Eisenhower the
history department at Columbia rallied
behind Stevenson as an intellectual who
could but of course historians are not
that much of a voting bloc and
Eisenhower won in a landslide Hofstadter
wit thereupon retreated almost
completely from politics he wrote to
sway dose after Stevenson's defeat I can
no longer describe myself as a radical
but I don't consider myself a
conservative either I suppose the truth
is although my interests are still
political I nonetheless have no politics
he just retreated from politics
altogether but what he did have was a
growing sense of the fragility of
intellectual freedom in the United
States his next book was the development
of academic freedom in the United States
written with his colleague Walter
Metzger published in 1955 Hofstadter
viewed McCarthyism as the outgrowth of a
deep-seated anti intellectualism and
provincialism among in the American
population the this attitude reinforced
this distrust of mass politics that are
rigid that really it originated when he
left the Communist Party and it was
reinforced by his search for new way
of understanding political behavior he
had started out with the beardian
assumption that politics just reflects
economic interests now he became
fascinated with other explanations of
political conducts status anxieties
irrational hatreds paranoia influenced
by the popularity of Freudianism among
New York intellectuals of the 50s and by
his interest in the social sciences and
literary criticism his friends see right
Mills Lionel trilling Alfred kaizen he
became more and more sensitive to the
importance of symbolic conduct and
unconscious motivations he applied these
to his next books on American political
culture which made clear his alienation
from what he called America's periodic
fits of moral crusading that's his quote
the age of reform 1955 offered an
interpretation of populism and
progressivism quite different from what
he had written in the past in his
master's essay he had seen the you know
it sympathized with the struggles of
downtrodden southern tenant farmers now
he portrayed the populist of the late
19th century as simply small businessmen
standing against the inevitable tide of
economic development and taking refuge
in a nostalgic agrarian myth lashing out
and imagined enemies from British
bankers to Jews in a precursor of modern
authoritarian movements as for the
progressives they were a displaced
bourgeoisie seeking in political reform
a way to overcome they had decline in
social status with their infatuation
with the idea of pure democracy
progressives were the source he said of
some of our most troublesome delusions
about politics
a similar sensibility informed his next
two books anti intellectualism in
American Life 1963 which identified an
American heartland quote filled with
people who are fundamentalist and
religion nativist and prejudiced
isolationist and foreign policy and
conservative in economics and all of
that was a serious danger
intellectual life two years later he
published the paranoid style in American
politics a collection of essays that
suggested that a common irrationality
characterized popular enthusiasms of
both the left and the right throughout
American history
he was particularly alarmed by the rise
of Barry Goldwater which triggered
further anxieties about the
irrationality of mass politics and had
parallels he felt to the earlier rise of
fascism in Europe in the last in the
last couple of months
Hof status distrust of mass democracy
has one new converts I can't I can't
count the number of times
reporters we're in a journalism school
here but I would have to say reporters
looking just for a kind of a brand a tag
to put on things have called me and
asked if the Trump campaign reflected
Hofstadter's paranoid style as I say I
think as Trump himself well understands
having a good brand name is desirable
whether for historical analysis or a
real estate empire to me the analysis
seemed superficial actually the paranoid
style it seemed to it seemed to
fundamentally be part of this consensus
vision that the American political
system was fundamentally sound and its
critics all essentially irrational but
Hoff said it was too Pro tea an
intellectual to remain satisfied with
that framework especially as social
turmoil engulfed the country in the mid
1960s as we saw he did join a contingent
of historians who flew to Selma he
didn't actually March he flew to Selma
to be there with these other historians
for the last day of the Martin Luther
King's March from Selma the flew to
Montgomery for the last day of the March
- from Selma to Montgomery in the
progressive historians since book of
1968 he attempted to come to terms
for all with the beardian legacy but now
he said that the the portrait of an
America racked by persistent conflict
was overdrawn but by the same token he
said the consensus view could hardly
explain the American Revolution the
Civil War or by implication the discord
in the country in the 1960s he went on
to edit American violence in 1970 with
his graduate student Michael Wallace and
his last book unfinished when he died
America at 1750 was the first volume of
a proposed three volume narrative
history of the nation but the picture of
colonial American society in that book
was fought darker then many people
expected it put a lot of emphasis on
indentured servitude on slavery on
inequality and as I say it remained
unfinished and only a tantalizing
suggestion of what his full account of
American history might have been I want
to end just on a quick personal note
Hofstadter had more influence on me than
any other teacher I encountered at
Columbia he supervised my senior thesis
as an undergraduate he supervised my
doctoral dissertation and I got to know
him very well for all this
accomplishments he was utterly without
pretentious always unintimidating never
too busy to talk with a student about
his work he did not try to impose his
views on his students no Hofstadter
school arose out of Columbia because he
did not try to force people into a
single mold it often seemed in the 1960s
that his graduate students were having
more influence on him than he was on us
as certainly in terms of what was going
on in the society
Hofstadter was not it's fair to say a
great teacher he wasn't all that
interested in teaching he once told me I
am a writer I teach in order to make a
living
he almost seemed out of his way good to
go out of his way to make his lectures
unappealing perhaps to drive away some
of the large numbers who
enrolled for his courses he was at his
best in small seminars and in individual
consultations and when criticizing
written work I learned much of what I
know about writing from Hofstadter's
comments on my own my own work
so hop set had died at a very young age
he left a prolific body of work
remarkable for its originality and its
readability and his capacity to range
over the length and breadth of American
history and I think a hundred years
after his birth his writing still stand
as a model of what historical
scholarship at its finest can achieve so
that is a little summary of Richard
Hofstadter and now I can't close it yeah
I got it so good evening everyone I'm
delighted to be here I should start by
saying that I never knew Richard
Hofstadter but I always felt linked to
him by a multi-generational chain of
mentors my UC Berkeley PhD advisor Paula
fasts was his student so he was very
much in the room as I was learning to be
an historian and I should also say that
I have long admired Hofstadter as an
historian for the following reasons I've
admired the clarity and power of his
writing and I will share some quotes
from him in my remarks so we can hear
his voice the boldness of his
argumentation his forte was his
argumentation he was not really an
archival historian his refusal to be
classified as a practitioner of one kind
of history he was not solely an
intellectual historian or social
historian or political historian he
aspired to speak to all of those fields
and I also admired that he resisted
our professions tendency to narrowly
pigeonhole historians into one
historical period he tried and he did
weigh in on many historical problems
from 1750 to 1968 this program was
planned several months ago by Ty Jones
but it couldn't be more relevant today
many of us whatever our political
persuasions have been struggling I'd say
over the last year if not more but
particularly since November 8th
about what to do with the mounting
evidence that our country is deeply
divided and that those divisions have
become vitriolic and downright nasty the
u.s. is looking less and less like a
beacon of democracy in a world filled
with political instability
totalitarianism
and terrorism as a Nestorian in
particular I find myself asking what is
my role at this moment of crisis how can
I contribute what are my
responsibilities as a Nestorian of the
United States and as a citizen of this
country and I'm sure that members in the
audience who are from other professions
and occupations are asking themselves
the same question so I'd like to use my
time today
to probe how Richard Hofstadter's life
and career might help me and us to
answer those questions I should note
that I'm not alone in looking towards
Hofstadter for guidance Eric mentioned
the phone calls he's been getting when
the Boston Globe asked historians and
other pundits on October 20th what books
were helping them make sense of the
present moment
both Hofstadter's age of reform and his
paranoid style of American American
politics were mentioned prominently and
despite this despite the fact that he
has been dead almost a half-century so
what can we learn from rich
hofstadter as a great historian whose
work is still read and appreciated today
and who was a politically aware and
committed citizen of the United States
this is a question that Hofstadter in
fact thought a lot about he felt
historians needed to be engaged with the
world his largest project was the
defense of liberalism from a
conservative right and by the end of his
life a radical left he did not argue for
the neutral social scientist who kept a
distance from key issues of his or her
time he once said in 1960 and I quote I
know it is risky but I still write
history out of my engagement with the
present but Hofstadter meant something
quite specific by that he felt
historians should not be instrumental
with their history using history and
service of a mom of a momentary and
sometimes fleeting political agenda they
should not as historian David Greenberg
put it in an admiring Atlantic magazine
essay about Hofstadter that he published
in 1998 and I quote from David here
turned the past into an ideological tool
rather Hofstadter felt historians should
speak to their current moments but do so
in a way that did not require abandoning
their responsibilities as historians to
write good history he had seen too many
abuses of history in the extremes of
fascism and communism Hofstadter wrote
in the tumultuous days of 1968 with a
full understanding of this dilemma and I
quote him historians are troubled
troubled about their own role and
function caught between their desire to
count in the world and their desire to
understand it on one side their passion
for understanding points back to the old
interest in detachment in neutrality in
critical history and the scientific
ideal but the terrible urgency of our
political problems points in another
direction plays upon their pragmatic
impulse their desire to get out of
history some lessons that will be of use
to the world end quote
so as sympathetic as Hofstadter was to
certain political causes he who had
confronted McCarthyism was deeply
invested as you heard in Adlai
Stevenson's race against Eisenhower in
1952 and was an early opponent of the
Vietnam War and I thought he marched in
Montgomery but apparently he supported
civil rights there in 1965 he
nonetheless rejected what I will call
here the advocate historian here he is
describing what he considered to be the
wrong course the sword of his this is a
quote from Hofstadter the sort of
historian who is half a publicist who
attempts above all to relate historical
inquiry to the current intellectual
milea and to current political problems
and who is willing to take the
consequent risks overstatement partial
views and momentarily distorted
perspectives such historians are
hopefully aware that our social location
as Karl Mannheim once observed may be as
much a source of insight as it is of
error so I would characterize
Hofstadter's position as arguing that
the historians job is to deepen our
understanding of the past and to find
their insights that can help us move
forward without manipulating history for
instrumental ends now I want to propose
what I think are some of those insights
that Richard Hofstadter were he alive
today might have wanted to remind us of
and there are three the first is that
ideas matter
one of Hofstadter's major intellectual
inspirations Erik mentioned this as well
as his favorite dueling partner was the
great progressive historian charles
beard who famously argued that the
financial interests of the founding
fathers can best explain the nation's
founding document the Constitution of
the United States
Hofstadter in contrast to beard believed
that ideas have an independent force
and cannot be solely reduced to economic
interests and that ideas and interests
are intimately related as he put it in
beard and the Constitution and I quote
before one could go very far in
examining how ideas and interests are
related the point had to be established
and established against considerable
resistance that they were so intimately
and universally related that no phase of
political life could be exempted from
this principle that a sacred symbol like
the Constitution could at least in this
respect be treated in the same light as
a railway franchise end quote
I see Hofstadter's insistence that ideas
matter to be one answer to those of us
who are baffled that so many
working-class Americans could have voted
in a way that seems contrary to their
economic interests Hofstadter reminds us
that political ideas ideas cannot be
reduced simply to economic self-interest
another aspect of ideas mattering to
Hofstadter relates to the complex
challenge of figuring out if and what
ideas and values are shared across
segments of the American population even
while also acknowledging the diversity
of values existing in a pluralistic
American society Hofstadter was inclined
to speak of the American mind in a
unitary way as did many historians of
his generation that unity contrasted
greatly with the previous generation of
progressive historians who identified
deep class cleavages Hofstadter's
anti-intellectualism in American life of
1963 and the paranoid style of American
politics of 1964 both aimed at getting
at that common mentality and mindset
today we are much more prone to focus on
social and ideological differences
rather than on consensus we focus on the
multitude of identities and views that
flourish within the u.s. we even take
that dissection to the point of mapping
complex cross-cutting identities that
che
individuals through what we now call
intersectionality but in a moment of
political crisis like this one now we
are seeing individuals and leaders on
the right and on the left frequently
invoking quintessential American values
that they feel their opponents are
dangerously violating whether from the
left who feels it is upholding a
tradition of Tolerance that the right is
abusing or on the part of the right a
rejection of centralized government and
a commitment to individual rights our
contemporaries are suddenly assuming
that such transcendent ideas have in
fact existed over time as historians we
might fruitfully contribute to this
debate by probing whether and how
consensus might have existed around
certain ideas and ideals and if so how
it was learned and how it was
communicated the other two points that I
think Hofstadter might have made
referred to to institutions that he
deeply valued and thought were important
sources of American democratic stability
those are political parties and
universities the first to take first the
political parties in the idea of a party
system of 1969 it was one of
Hofstadter's last works he argued that
the founders feared that conflicting
parties would destroy the young Republic
but that the opposite in fact proved
true he celebrated it and I quote the
emergence of legitimate party opposition
and of a theory of politics that
accepted it as something new in the
history of the world the party system he
argued legitimize loyal opposition and
provided the stability that so many
Democratic Republic's historically had
lacked so if alive today Hofstadter
might have urged us to double down and
rather than despair direct our energies
toward reinvigorating both parties so
that they better reflect the broad-based
constituencies that a two-party system
depends on for vitality and stability
eventually Hofstadter himself conceded
that Eisenhower had triumphed over his
much admired Stevenson because and I
quote the time for change in the parties
was overdue if the two-party system was
to have any meaning and quote that's
from anti-intellectualism finally
Hofstadter might very well have told us
to safeguard at all costs the academic
freedom of the University and make the
university a sanctuary for important
liberal values when the nation is in
political crisis Hofstadter thought a
lot about the university he saw it as a
site of instruction a free inquiry and
criticism and not a societal with a site
of societal reform per se when he took a
political stand on campus such as in
challenging military and CIA recruiting
at Columbia or recommending against
amnesty for those protesters who had
occupied buildings he felt he was
protecting the sacred and fragile
independence of the university as and I
quote from his 1968 Columbia
commencement address a community of a
special kind a community devoted to
inquiry it exists so that its members
may inquire into truths of all sorts so
let me just say in conclusion that I
don't think Donald Trump's victory would
have surprised Richard Hofstadter
after all he tracked extremists revolt
in the heartland of America from the
populace of the 1890s to the anti urban
nativists of the 1920s to the McCarthy
i'ts and other anti communists in the
1950s to the Goldwater campaigners of
1964 and as you heard from Eric the
potential political power of the masses
in fact frightened him Hofstetter
even foresaw the impact of the media
celebrity on politics when he eerily
wrote in 1964 and I quote the growth of
the mass media of communication and
their use in politics have
politics closer to the people that ever
before and have made politics a form of
entertainment in which the spectators
feel themselves involved thus it has
become more than ever before an arena
into which private emotions and personal
problems can be readily projected end
quote and yet despite being a master at
irony at contradiction and paradox in
his history writing Hofstadter
resisted cynicism and withdrawal and
political life at his memorial service
the yale historian C Vann Woodward said
and I quote him he never joined the
fashionable cult of anti-americanism
despite some disappointments and
disillusionment Hofstadter stayed the
course resilience as an historian and as
the citizen and dedicated to protecting
the values and institutions he believed
were so fundamental to a liberal
democratic society I feel fairly certain
that he would urge us to do the same
today thank you
well what uh what an honor and treat to
be here I didn't know richard hofstadter
as nearly as well as my dear friend Eric
but I had the privilege of writing a
senior thesis under his supervision on
race riots of 1919 but in truth the
first time I met professor Hofstadter
was at the home of then Dean of the
college David Truman I served on what
was known as an academic affairs
committee a committee that was addressed
by Dean Truman in our first time we met
that I met with that committee in which
he told us that what had happened that
Berkeley and 64 could never happen at
Columbia we were simply too close to the
faculty and the faculty the students but
so much for predictive political science
in any event David Truman was a
wonderful dean of the college
extraordinary Dean of the college
actually and it was at his home that I
first came across Richard Hofstadter and
the first thing I ever heard I won't say
words the first thing I ever heard
Richard Hofstadter say was imitating a
garbage truck that had been keeping him
awake at night he was a great mimic as
Eric will know and extremely funny but
by the time I wanted to write a senior
thesis despite having with him despite
having taken a lecture class with him
that had all the qualities that
professor Foner noted I applied but by
that time I had written my first
published piece which was a critical
review of the paranoid style that
appeared in in The Spectator I I didn't
have the courage before this event to go
back and read it it was a pretty callow
critique but when I was interviewed by
professor Hofstadter he he said to me
one of his first sentences he said I I
did enjoy your your article but have you
ever come across the notion of a
misplaced modifier and the the the the
second writing lesson I had was he
taught I'm empowered to do this because
Eric mentioned the senior thesis that
had not been in my plan but never mind
he he taught a great lesson in my very
first meeting with him he said you know
you will never know what you think until
you write and even if much of what you
write will end up in the trash as much
of my writing he said ends up in the
trash you will profit by writing things
out so he said I don't know if you had
the same experience he said each week
you will write five pages and bring them
to me which I did and week two now
arrives and professor Hofstadter took my
five pages from my hands and proceeded
to read them back to me he had just won
his second Pulitzer one of the great
stylists of all time and in sentence
three or four he took his reading specs
off and said surely mr. Katznelson
there's a more felicitous way to make
that point I hear him say that all the
time and then it was my really great
privilege he used to call me mr. Katz
Nelson but in nineteen the fall of
nineteen I was in the spring 6566
academic year but in 1969 I joined the
faculty as an assistant professor I had
an office in Hamilton Hall one floor on
the eighth floor he was on the seventh
as I recall and one day we we rode the
elevator together only faculty then were
allowed to get in that elevator so it
was one of my first privilege was I
could ride the elevator my second
privilege was there was Richard
Hofstadter and he said oh hi iris oh
nice to see you again and the movement
from mr. cass nelson to ira is one of
the
cherished moments of my life I only
deeply regret that he already didn't
look very well and didn't alas survive
his leukemia now my comments are
principally about his own self
description of two kinds professor
Hofstadter and I still that comes to me
I Richard Hofstadter professor
Hofstadter
self described as a radical liberal
that's his word his term and the second
self description comes out of an essay
he wrote in a book edited by Fritz turn
varieties of history he self-described
as an analytical historian and what I
would like in my remarks to talk about
is the relationship between being an
analytical historian and being a radical
liberal so just read the analytic
historian this is 1955 in an essay
history and the social sciences
Hofstadter wrote the next generation may
see the development of a somewhat new
historical genre which will be a mixture
of traditional history and the social
sciences I think the reference to the
social sciences here primarily was a
reference to his fascination with
psychology at the time and not just
Freud but including Freudian psychology
in any event it will differ from the
narrative history of the past in that
its primary purpose will be analytical
it will differ from the typical
historical monograph of the past in that
it will be more consciously designed as
a literary form and we'll focus on types
of problems that the monograph has all
too often failed to raise it will be
informed by the insights of the social
sciences and at some points will make
use of the methods they have originated
it without pretending to be scientific
analytical history may welcome and more
reciprocal interest and provide more
stimulation for social scientists than a
great deal of the history now being
written and I believe he was a great
analytical historian always interested
in causation and not just in
storytelling but causation not in a very
crib narrow sense of over emphasis on
getting a cause right but on giving us
large-scale portraits of fundamental
features of the American experience that
were causal in his view but analytical
history for what and about what and
that's where his radical liberalism
enters the picture he was deeply
concerned to understand what might be
called the hearts problem the nature of
the liberal tradition in America he had
a very complicated relationship to the
work of Louis hearts I think Eric Foner
had it exactly right when he said that
like hearts Hofstadter saw that which
was common or even consensual in
American history not as a success story
but as a constraint insufficiently
reflected on by most by many historians
it should be said and I'm now quoting a
footnote from one of my two favorite
Hofstadter books this is the progressive
historians which is his late in life
assessment of Turner beard and
Parrington my other favorite books
actually America at 1750 both for what
didn't get realized but also for that
really powerful emphasis on nachos black
servitude but on white servitude as well
in the in the colonial era we were not
simply born free
was telling us and we were not simply
born free enslaved but in some kind of
remarkably complex combination he writes
I must warn unsuspecting readers that in
discussing the so-called consensus
school I am discussing a tendency with
which my own work has been associated I
suppose the first statement however
brief and inarticulate of the consensus
idea was in my introduction to the
American political tradition and it is
developed fragmentarily in other
writings not least my comments on beard
however I have resolved not to discuss
my own work in these pages and I hope to
present my attitude toward consensus
history so far as I must as essentially
ambivalent and then but what was
striking to me are two features of this
discussion first is where he fully
agrees with hearts he writes when the
political spectrum is laid out against
the spectra of European countries it can
be seen in its naked brevity its
simplicity its lack of range all
American thinking except for a brief
luminous creative but basically diluted
reactionary episode arising out of the
pro-slavery argument is huddled around
the Lockean Center that's both the
summary of hearts but an appreciation of
hearts but he goes on to say something
which I think hearts would have might
have had more trouble with or at least
most readings of hearts think he would
have had more trouble he writes he
Hofstadter yet I think it is a valid
comment on the limits of consensus
history to insist that in one form or
another conflict finally does remain and
ought to remain somewhere near the
center of our focus of attention so this
is a not consensus instead of conflict
but locating conflict within the image
he used a picture frame but conflict
about what conflict about the character
of the liberal tradition in America and
Hofstadter was a critic as David Donald
once
observe from the inside he became a
fierce liberal critical of the liberal
tradition from the inside now how did he
do that it seems to me that he worked at
the margins of three sets of
relationships this is my own take
having's have done some rereading for
this event but I I'm declaring it in
declarative sentences it really deserves
question marks I think there are three
pairs of items that fascinated professor
Hofstadter from the social Darwinism
book to America at 1750 the first I
would call the relationship between
structure and experience Hofstadter
spent a lot of time in his work creating
a contextual portrait of the world in
which he was analyzing trying to explain
how it was that structure was altering
it could be as a result of demography in
colonial America it could be as a result
of industrialization or an agrarian
crisis but he always wanted to know
there was a kind of under determination
of experience as a result of structure
the the Marxist aunt part of him
remained if that is there's this causal
power in big structural changes but what
we make of these structural changes is
under determined by the structure itself
so the first link is structure and
experience the second linkage inhofe
it's a ters work that I think was
fundamental is the linkage between what
might be called experience and
interpretation or experience and
dispositions that human beings
experience structural changes in certain
ways he insisted did not determine how
they would interpret those experiences
and much of his work whether it's about
social Darwinism as a as a way of
thinking or it's about other dimensions
of ideas is about is asking us to know
that experience itself does not
determine interpretation and finally
there's the linkage between
interpretation dispositions on the one
side and behavior on the other so Y
populace did what they did or why the
New Deal had the policies that it had
didn't follow immediately from
dispositions and in each of those
dimensions I think what joined
Hofstadter's work together was that with
respect to each of these relationships
he was a profound institutionalist he
believed whether it was the party system
or the university or and you can make a
list of institutions that appear in his
work it is the institutional qualities
of political liberalism and by political
liberalism I don't mean partisan
liberalism I mean the tradition of rule
of law individual rights government by
consent political representation the
Lockean liberal tradition it's the
institutional instantiation of that
liberal tradition that for Hofstadter
altered the probabilities of how
structure would be linked to experience
how experience would be linked to
dispositions how dispositions would be
linked to action and to understand
liberalism and its fate realistically to
do that required an analysis at each of
those levels with an institutional
Sensibility
two final things before I sit down I
think I have no way of knowing what I'm
about to say is true but I believe that
a critical institution professor
Hofstadter belonged to when he was quite
young at Columbia late 40s early 50s
into the mid 50s that he belonged to
shaped if not decisively shaped
importantly the way he became an
analytical historian and developed as an
animal
historian and the way he used analytical
history to critically assess and grapple
with the tradition he came to appreciate
so much that of the Western liberal
tradition and the institution I'm
referring to was called at Columbia the
seminar on the state its members
included Bob Merton David Truman the
Walter Metzger Peter gay see right mills
Franz Newman Fritz turn they gathered
regularly to discuss texts together at a
moment following the second war when the
capacities of the liberal tradition and
liberal enlightenment had proved so
fragile so incapable of
a battling evil and this group this
seminar in the state had as its agenda
it's explicit agenda I've been through
all their minutes for a series of
lectures I gave some years ago had as
their explicit agenda the creation of
what might be called a non credulous
enlightenment a less innocent
enlightenment a less innocent liberalism
but still a liberalism committed to its
fundamental values and I just want to
end if I may by reading briefly two
things first is and look at Elizabeth's
if Nina's here empowers me to read this
side I have a letter in my hand from
Fritz Stern which was written I didn't
know I had it I mean I've told this
afternoon I was I knew I had it but I
know it was in this book well that I was
carrying with me for this evening and he
wrote the following it was in reading he
happily he read this little book of mine
it was in reading it the obvious
occurred to me in the 1930s and 1940s
into the 1950s the period of the seminar
in the state the attack on the
Enlightenment came
overwhelmingly from the outside and when
this attack was beaten back we could
both affirm and criticize now the attack
comes largely from within and in some
ways it is much more invidious alas I
think that may be true of our current
situation and I just want to end by
reading Hofstadter this is page 454 of
the progressive historians finally he
says there is a sutler more intangible
but vital kind of moral consensus that I
call comity comity exists in a society
to the degree that those enlisted in its
contending interests have a basic
minimal regard for each other one part
of your interest seeks the defeat of an
opposing interest on matters of policy
but at the same time seeks to avoid
crushing the opposition denying the
legitimacy of its existence or its
values were inflicting upon an extreme
and gratuitous humiliation beyond the
substance of the gains that are being
thought the basic humanity of the
opposition must not be forgotten
civility is not abandoned the sense that
a community life must be carried on
after the acerbic issues of the moment
have been fought over and one is seldom
very far of mine out of mind an
awareness that the opposition will
Sunday be the government is always
present and he concludes by talking
about what interwar Europe was like when
this sense of comity and civility was
lost writing about the Spanish Civil War
and he ended the paragraph where Spain
might be taken as the example of a
society that failed to develop comity
the bimah Republic is a case history of
its gradual but accelerating breakdown
may we not lose the sense of comity
good evening so I was born probably
eight months after Richard Hofstadter
passed away so I definitely did not know
him and I but I was have been very
privileged to work with historians here
at Columbia who were influenced by him
and so and it is such a pleasure to be
here I'm thank Ty Jones for the
invitation and I'm really humbled to be
presenting with these three panelists
because their work far more than
Professor Hofstadter's has really
influenced my development as a historian
with the ascendancy of Donald Trump
the term populist has reemerged with a
vengeance in the mainstream media I know
you've been hearing it as much as I have
journalists flooded the airwaves and
websites with mentions of the word
populist and populism throughout the
presidential campaign I did a LexisNexis
search that turned up the words populist
or populism alongside the name Trump a
total of more than 2000 times in the
major American newspapers since Trump
announced his presidential bid in June
of 2015 on the major cable news networks
newscasters and Talking Heads uttered
the words upwards of 1,700 times during
the same period
CNN used it the most at 1,100 Fox News
used at the least 237 if I had my way I
would ban its use because the word
populist simultaneously discredits and
legitimizes the angry politics of
working-class white men rather than
inviting them to imagine and work toward
a more broad-based initiative for the
most part journalists
journalists use the word in seemingly
benign way to signify a mass social
movement but they also use it to divide
and to discredit the working class
supporters who make up Trump's political
base the word populist is meant to call
to mind the image of rowdy and resentful
white men with an axe to grind against
the elite and tough-talking irreverent
leaders who appeal to people's fears and
Pit one group against another to gain
votes Trump's use of xenophobic racist
and retrograde language certainly is in
line with what an earlier generation of
scholars attributed to the 19th century
populist the work of Richard Hofstadter
played a major role in making populist a
fixture of contemporary American
political discourse Hofstadter was the
most prominent of a group of historians
political scientists and sociologists
responsible for shaping the various ways
scholars and the public defined the word
writing during the early years of the
Cold War
Hofstadter interpreted the late 19th
century populist party in memorably
unfavorable terms in age of reform
populist advance of Hofstadter advances
infamous status politics thesis he
argued that the populist were not yeoman
farmers losing their grip on landed
independence but instead were closeted
capitalists merely concerned about
losing status they expressed their
concerns in backward ignorant
anti-semitic and fiercely anti modern
ways rather than looking forward
they were harkening back to a mythical
agrarian past to maintain a homogeneous
what he called a homogeneous Yankee
civilization Hofstadter's interpretation
of the populist was a product of the
Cold War moment in which he was writing
in trying to make sense of Joseph
McCarthy's anti-communist crusade
Hofstadter and other scholars seized
upon the rural men and women who
supported the populist party of the 19th
century as the forebears of
backward and reactionary people who
supported McCarthyism this
interpretation of populism endured and
spread to describe a broad list of
politicians during the 1960's and 1970's
from george wallace to john d
rockefeller the forth yet by the 1970s
Hofstadter himself conceded that he had
created more of a character caricature
than a historical interpretation of the
populist according to his friend C Vann
Woodward the scholarship of the past 40
years or so certainly has moved toward a
reading of the party that emphasizes its
revolutionary contributions to advancing
democracy and its brief success in
sustaining a coalition of black and
white farmers nevertheless the current
use of small p populism in our public
discourse partly rest on the set of
assumptions inherent in Hofstadter's
original critique of the populist with a
big P first bigotry was central to his
analysis and it continues to figure into
how journalists used the word today even
though populist is an ugly word it now
serves as a sanitized synonym for racist
which is considered to be an even uglier
slur like the word race which Barbara
and Karen fields argue has become a
seemingly polite but evasive substitute
for racism the word populist has less of
a sting perhaps the term populist serves
the commercial interest of mainstream
journalists by allowing them to bring to
the reader or viewers mind the bigotry
of some white voters without having to
directly call them races thus avoiding
the risk of alienating a core audience
the word populism populist also
contributes to a racist double standard
by setting apart and elevating the
concerns of white working-class men from
everyone else at the same time the word
is incredibly unfair to the vast
majority of white working-class people
they have been slapped with a label and
continually discredited as anti
intellectual even though Kyle
educated suburban white women ended up
supporting Trump in surprising numbers
no one would include such women under
the populist banner the use of the word
populist today also captures the
backward-looking perspective that
Hofstadter attributed to the 19th
century populist the make America great
again slogan of the Trump campaign fits
with Hofstadter's interpretation that
populist were yearning for the return of
a past that had never really existed
Trump invited his supporters to
entertain the illusion that he could
return the country to the vaguely
defined glory days of America's past the
wall the Muslim ban and mass
deportations of undocumented workers are
only some of the solutions he's promised
his hateful rhetoric has also left room
for supporters and opponents alike to
fill in the blank with all sorts of
other troubling scenarios from
internment camps to the re-establishment
of slavery one of the problems with
journalists coverage of Trump supporters
is that it not only reveals their racism
but also unwittingly validates and
reinforces it the media could have
focused on the widespread economic
distress of all working-class people as
a counterpoint to the narrative of white
working-class people as the sole victims
of economic distress instead news
stories continue to leave the impression
that white working-class men are not
supposed to experience the same economic
problems as everyone else
journalists unwittingly legitimize
Trump's abhorrent rhetoric and white
workers outrage over the bleak economic
hardship that non-white over economic
difficulties they're facing while taking
for granted the equally bleak economic
hardship that non-white unemployed
underemployed and laid off workers face
the implication is that white
working-class people are the members of
society who are supposed to be
financially comfortable that they have a
birthright to prosperity the word
populist
perpetuates the vicious double standard
that the economic that economic
inequality toxic drinking water police
terror against citizens and other crimes
are considered within the realm of
normalcy for communities with
predominantly black populations and the
few white people unfortunate to live in
them but wholly disturbing and
unacceptable for the lily-white
communities of America's heartland the
word populist and the broader
assumptions that undergird it leaves the
false and dangerous impression that the
interest of white working-class people
aren't just different from those of
other Americans but at odds with them
another problem is that populist is now
being used to describe so many disparate
movements and phenomena that it no
longer has any meaning the term has been
applied to Bernie Sanders popular bid
for the Democratic nomination and at
least that's a more positive campaign
but and at one point Sanders even
embraced his campaign being called a
populist uprising likewise the word
populist is widespread and media
discussions of a range of movements and
leaders abroad in a recent issue of
Foreign Affairs Fareed Zakaria of CNN
argued that we're currently experiencing
a populist upsurge throughout the
Western world he sees evidence of
populism in the UK Greece Spain Germany
and France the connection between the
word populist brexit and Donald Trump
has only magnified the negative
associations people have with the word
but the fact that the word has been also
used to describe Sanders and so many
other movements points to the problem
and the ambiguity of its meaning
much of the the misuse of the word I I
call it a misuse only because it doesn't
stay true to the history of the populist
party which could offer a more useful
way to imagine alternatives to the
country social political and economic
predicament perhaps the story of this
19th century political party and the
decades-long political mobilization that
preceded its founding would inspire a
coalition of working people capable of
reclaiming the Democratic promise of
populism the past 40 years of
scholarship emphasizes the boldness of
the populist proposals the populist took
aim at the unequal distribution of
wealth and income and the unjust
concentration of political power in the
hands of the wealthy they were
particularly disgusted by big business
corruption of government and government
selling out to business before there was
a populist party there were many
organizations cooperatives societies and
unions such as the Grange and the
Knights of Labor that fed into the
populist movement the most powerful
group was the farmers Alliance which was
founded in Texas in 1875 in three years
the Alliance grew to more than four
million members with a group of
lecturers in place and its own
newspapers the Alliance disciplined and
groomed legions of men and women who
would eventually join the ranks of the
populist party as organizers supporters
or officeholders the southern wing of
the farmers alliance was its most
assertive and determined the issues the
members of the southern farmers alliance
identified and thought through over many
years eventually became the key elements
of the populist party platform they
called for the abolition of the National
Bank's they proposed their own
alternative banking system they wanted
the federal government to control credit
and money and they sought an increase in
the supply of money in circulation by
employing the free coinage of silver
they also sought to break up monopolies
Institute an eight-hour labor law
and turn the railroad and telegraph
lines over to the control of the
government hofstadter x' interpretation
of this party and the current use of the
small p populism today both portray
populism as the exclusive provenance of
white men yet Omar Ali another Columbia
PhD and other scholars have established
the vital role of black men and women in
the movement during the 1880s they
founded the colored farmers Alliance to
promote self-help mutual aid and
improved farming techniques their
activism in the Alliance the populist
party and the fusion politics of the
1890s further undermines any claims that
populist were motivated motivated by
nostalgia for the agrarian past far from
harkening back to the days of slavery
these farmers were preoccupied with the
present and future and motivated like
other populist to safeguard their
ability to make a decent living for a
brief period poor white and black
southerners joined forces for example
Ali shows that in North Carolina black
Republicans and white populace joined
forces to take over the state government
and succeeded in putting funding in
place for public education and for
reforming voting rules those efforts to
unite black and white voters posed a
threat and were ended through violent
Appeals for white supremacy Jim Crow was
a direct response to populism if Donald
Trump bares any historical resemblance
to a figure from the late 19th century
its pitchfork Ben Tillman of South
Carolina or furnivall Simmons of North
Carolina politicians who freely use the
language of demagoguery and white
supremacy to destroy the populist party
and to end democracy in their states
just as Hofstede's interpretation
influenced the way that we use populism
today in our political discourse
historians and public intellectuals
today can hold up a few crucial aspects
about the 19th century
populist party as a model for
working-class and middle-class people
who want good jobs for themselves and
their children the men and women who
eventually supported the populist party
did so after decades of organizing on
the local and state level and educating
themselves to viable alternatives
writing during the early 1970s C Vann
Woodward distinguished between the
populist party and the so-called new
populist he said lacking discipline and
political education the new populist are
more susceptible to demagogic appeal in
dragging them into national politics
prematurely presidential candidates act
in a parasitic rather than a
constructive role and may dissipate the
sentiment before it achieves coherence
just as Trump and Steve Bannon and
company are stubborn in their approach
and rhetoric historians and public
intellectuals must be intractable in
exposing people to a politics that rests
on organization and concrete proposals
not division and craft talk we will
always be susceptible to the charge that
as academics we are far removed from the
concerns of working-class men and women
in western Pennsylvania or Idaho or
South Dakota but with a vast and growing
number of contingent faculty and
unemployed PhDs in our profession I
would argue that we too know something
about the economic look dislocations and
stagnating wages besetting the nation no
field is immune from widespread income
inequality our difficulties are as far
removed from what the populist party
tried to tackle nevertheless the day to
day thinking and organizing their
movement exemplifies can inform our
imaginations as Robert McMath wrote of
the populist there's is a legacy waiting
to be fulfilled thank you
I think if the panel doesn't object I'm
gonna throw the floor open for a few
minutes we're running a little over time
but there is a microphone here if
anybody has a question or a comment they
would like to pose to the panelists or
anybody particularly please come along
to this microphone here if not I will
see if anybody on the panel was to add a
word or two by the way I want to commend
Adrienne particularly because I've been
in my own little way fighting a totally
losing battle against the use and misuse
of of the term populist by political
journalists in this in this election I
even have a former student who writes a
column for the Financial Times of London
wrote a whole column about how crazy I
was trying to stop journalist this
professor doesn't want us to use the
word populist because you know and he
quoted me and then he said well we're
gonna do it anyway so forget it you know
shows you how much influence we have so
I just it does anybody here want to add
anything to what has been said and if
not I will just invite people to there
are there is some there are some
refreshments in the back wine some other
things I don't even know what they are
because they were covered but I they
look like something to eat
so here we go yes one why don't you go
up to the microphone so people can hear
you should also toast his birthday let's
not forget why we're here
well it's true its 100th birthday of
richard hofstadter that's right yes I
just wanted to ask if anybody had a
comment the other thing that we're
reading in the last few days commonly in
the in the papers is the references to
Richard Rorty
and how that is being applied as a way
of interpreting the the failures of the
left and the failures of the Democratic
Party to
understand why Trump was about to win
the election and I wonder if there's a
connection anyone sees between
Hofstadter's writings and these comments
that have been quoted endlessly from
rorty's achieving achieving our country
and were perhaps what you think
Hofstadter would have made of rorty's
focus on identity politics versus socio
economic issues I know I won't speak to
Morty but I do think you're onto
something important which is that HOF
setters own kind of fears of the
politics of the masses is a blind spot I
think that liberal democratic politics
still carries and I think you could
argue that the Clinton campaign also
suffered from that not quite not you
know just not taking seriously enough
and I think Adrienne's comments were
also addressing that the real-life
dilemmas and the Sanders campaign did
raise those questions and was somewhat
you know batted down so I do think that
you know the only dilemmas he had
himself as a liberal are ones that
liberal democratic politics carried
today and it's something we're gonna
have to deal with if we're gonna come
back and really speak to a broad base of
the nation though we do have to remind
ourselves that she did win the popular
vote true enough any other comment or
question if not I think it's probably
too late to start going into the
philosophy of Richard Rorty which is
hope we could have a whole other evening
about that so I with that I want to just
thank the library Tyrone's etc for
organizing this and invite people to
partake of the little reception right in
the back of the room
okay